bonjour à tous on est aujourd'hui en w
c'est sur le stand via omis en attendant
la sortie prochaine l'annoncent
prochaine du mx2 est ce l'âge aidant la
main le mx2 et d'un polype sorte qu'ils
étaient lancés les dernières parties
[Musique]
un produit qui est vraiment très très
bien un écran format 18/9 5,99 pouces au
format 2160 par 1080 pixels
y a pas à dire le format 19e c'était
vraiment la grande révolution en 2017 ça
va continuer on va aller plus loin
encore en 2018 avec des grands écrans
toujours plus immersive toujours la
qualité
le mix de vesdre à beaurains un dragon
845 le mix de 1st dragonne 830 50 à
danser à 2.45 gigahertz et très bien la
flyer qui marche très bien
c'est vrai que c'est un produit qui est
super intéressant il a 8 gigas de ram
côté sept huit mois se trouve vraiment
sympa vous avez vraiment ce très grand
écran sur la face avant
vraiment très pratique à l'arrière un
dos en verre sympa il est bien
évidemment des traces de doigts ça je
dirais que c'est un grand classique on
retrouve aujourd'hui sur tous les
smartphones vous avez ici votre caméra
avec votre flash à côté le capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui positionnait
en dessous je trouve que le
positionnement du capteur d'empreinte
digitale est pas idéal parce que lorsque
vous allez cherchez vous trouvez là mais
vous avez rapidement tendance à aller
grappiller un petit peu le haut de
l'appareil photo du coup de laisser des
traces de doigts dessus bon ça c'est un
petit peu
point que je regrette également chez
samsung mais bon tout cas c'est vrai que
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal pas mal
fichu le design est sympa c'est un
produit qui est très fin vous avez sur
le côté un bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre
le bouton de volume ici lecteur de carte
sim sur le côté très simple une caméra
sur l'avant qui n'est pas positionné en
haut quand on peut trouver sur les
autres smartphones mais qui est vraiment
planté ici
sur le coin en bas ça change un peu au
début ça peut perturber mais qu'au final
ça marche très très bien
c'est un produit qui seront sous android
7.1 méga l'appareil photo au dos et un
12 mégapixels à l'avant vous avez un
appareil photo 5 mégapixels vous pouvez
enregistrer en 4k où il a un bluetooth
5.0 de l'usb tilt c'est une batterie
3400 millions terreur et surtout et est
vendue au tarif de 380 euros
ça c'est vraiment très pratique c'est
toute la stratégie de viol mais tout
l'intérêt d'avoir des produits bio me
c'est effectivement l'intérêt d'avoir
des produits de bonne qualité pas cher
du tout on est vraiment sur des produits
d'entrée de gamme sur un produit qui est
par contre au niveau la fiche technique
est vraiment séduisant reste un dragon
835 couple à 8 gigas de ram
fondamentalement ça marche la batterie
est là c'est un produit qui fonctionne
bien après en terme de photos n'allez
pas lui demander d'aller chercher
vraiment du détail en faible luminosité
mais par contre pour utilisation je
dirais pour un smartphone classique avec
un écran 18 9e marche super bien
la prison d'un coup le produit sympa
sexy je regrette qu'il n'y ait pas deux
prises jack mais bon fondamentalement
sur un produit comme celui ci c'est pas
bien grave n'est pas là toute la
différence va se faire
autrefois c'était intéressant de ton
arrivée du xix omis cette année en
france ça c'est vraiment une excellente
nouvelle parce que des smartphones
d'entrée de gamme de ce prix là avec
cette qualité là il en existe bien
évidemment mais vous devez les commander
par internet là vous pourriez avoir
directement en france sans avoir à les
importer et c'est juste top c'est une
excellente nouvelle dites moi ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que vous avez déjà
des produits dédiés aux miss qui
pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que ça pourrait vous séduire est
ce qu'un produit comme le mx 2 points
vous intéresser le mx2 est ce qui va
arriver bientôt à rester connectés parce
qu'on va très prochainement en parler
mark et moi tout ça en commentaire to
david bien évidemment comme d'hab mais
c'est des jolis coups ça vous abonner
parce que
plus parler de produits innovants de
produits tech de smartphones de plein de
choses
donc c'est top merci beaucoup à très
bientôt soyez sages sylla et vous bien
[Musique]